[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
jt des territoires voici les titres de
l'actualité de cette édition
tout d'abord le télé achat en vogue les
magasins vont rester fermés vous le
savez le gouvernement a annoncé un
renforcement des mesures et des
contrôles nous irons prendre le pouls
dans la ville du mans où certains
commerçants se réinvente
grâce au numérique et au célèbre
téléachat la santé le grand vide et des
territoires vous emmène également cette
semaine dans la loire à saint-etienne
plus précisément pour visiter le plus
grand pôle de santé de la région
construit en lieu et place d'un centre
commercial en plein centre ville une
réponse certaine aux déserts médicaux
vous allez le voir enfin tout schuss
nous irons prendre l'air dans les vosges
à la découverte d'une micro station de
ski de moyenne montagne qui malgré le
réchauffement climatique et la crise a
décidé d'ouvrir ses pistes cet hiver
voilà et puis nous commençons ce grand
jt des territoires avec un renfort
précieux
il s'agit du shelter un hôpital mobile
unique au monde qui permet d'accueillir
18 passion dont huit en urgence absolue
et le tout déployé en seulement 20
minutes cet hôpital mobile était au
départ prévu pour faire face à des
situations de terrorisme ou de
catastrophes naturelles
il est le fruit d'une collaboration de
trois entre la région occitanie et la
région nouvelle aquitaine l'espagne et
l'andorre le shelter est déployé à
bayonne et accueille ses premiers
patients qu'ovide tous les détails avec
les équipes sur place devient occitanie
regardez c'est un renfort précieux en
ces temps de crise sanitaire
voici le chez le père un hôpital mobile
unique au monde
ici on peut accueillir 18 patients dont
huit en état d'urgence absolue et le
tout déployé en seulement 20 minutes
vous avez donc des banques ce soir vous
avez tout enfant né
le matériel est prise en charge des
patients et puis vous avez une salle de
soir avec de l'eau de l'eau potable
d'eaux chaudes le coffre pour mettre la
morphine le réfrigérateur le chauffeur
fusion le matériel avait tout est prévu
pour rendre à charge des patients dans
des conditions de confort qui sont
vraiment petits mâles c'est un tel
mobile était au départ prévu pour faire
face à des situations de terrorisme ou
de catastrophes industrielles
il est le fruit d'une collaboration de
trois ans entre la région occitanie la
nouvelle aquitaine l'espagne et andorre
le shelter a été déployé ce lundi après
midi devant le chu de bayonne
partenaires des toulousains et va
bientôt accueillir ses premiers patients
qu'aux vide l'unité est là parce que les
gens sont saturés et là parce que il ya
un partenariat il ya une anticipation et
une volonté à ce que les services ne
soient pas saturer pendant cette crise
qu vite cette unité va pouvoir nous
aider pour recevoir les patients des
urgences qui seront pris soin dans le
service d'urgence en du rck qui y six ou
sept unités là et parce qu'il faut aussi
penser qu' il n'y a pas que deco vide
qui sont graves il ya aussi des patients
donc au vide qui sont graves qui doivent
arriver à l'hôpital qui doit arriver aux
urgences ils doivent être pris en charge
correctement et cette unité là nous
permet de les prendre en très bonne
condition
voilà nous partons pour la nouvelle
équipe tiennent maintenant vous savez de
nombreux lycées ferme
alors comment faire pour que le niveau
des élèves soient maintenues et bien la
région a rouvert depuis quelques
semaines sa plate forme d' aide aux
devoirs
un service gratuit pour tous les lycéens
et apprentis de la région
plus de détails avec nos confrères de
tele7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest sur
place regarder quand vous avez complété
la définition du site arithmétique
cet étudiant de l'université de bordeaux
en master 2 de maths répondu lundi au
jeudi de 18h à 21h aux lycéens en
détresse face à leurs devoirs
un dispositif gratuit qui s'adresse à
tous les lycéens et apprentis de la
région nouvelle aquitaine verviers en
tant que tu te laisses en mathématiques
que ça soit et donc des leçons non
comprises au bien des exercices au qui
rencontrent des difficultés
cette plateforme téléphonique a pour
objectif de réduire les écarts entre les
élèves
elle permet ainsi à ceux dont
l'entourage ne peut apporter des aides
de trouver une oreille attentive et
gratuite
pas toujours facile de
de vous et qu'on se rendre compte qu'on
ne comprend pas bien un problème s'agit
de redonner confiance
nous nous sommes là sur sur la proche
québécoise du sujet et parle beaucoup
moins de décrochage que de nécessité de
stimuler la persévérance et ça fait
partie de notre objectif en trois heures
c'est parfois plus d'une quinzaine
d'appels reçus les jeunes qui parlent
aux jeunes une formule gagnante
ça m'a vraiment aidé parce que les
explications sont claires et comme c'est
des personnes de leur tranche d'âge
belle ça facilite un peu la
communication une aide aux devoirs qui
s'ajoutent à celles déjà présentes du
tutorat dans les collèges pour faire
redémarrer un ascenseur social en panne
voilà nous en rêvons tous en ces temps
de crise sanitaire
une tueuse de co vide nous partons pour
les yvelines ou une petite entreprise de
fontenay-le-fleury a décidé de se lancer
dans la production d'appareils tueur de
qu'ovide un projet grand public
destinées à désinfecter les objets de
votre bureau ou de votre domicile et ce
dans les moindres recoins
toutes les explications avec ce
reportage de nos confrères de tv 78 sur
place regardez une machine tueuse de
couronnes navires us c'est le projet
mise au point par cette entreprise de
fontenay le fleury
elle a choisi de chercher des solutions
pour aider à lutter contre l'épidémie de
lakovic 19 en mettant son activité
première de côté les deux machines qui
ont été créés la première c'est la lampe
uv storm qui a été conçu pour pouvoir
nettoyer de faire pour à désinfecter des
pièces par exemple une salle de réunion
un cabinet de médecin à une salle
d'école qui utilisent des des néons ubc
qui viennent bombardé entièrement toute
la pièce
la deuxième machine elle a été créée au
cours d'une rencontre on proposait notre
lampe à un opticien qui nous exprimer
son besoin lui de pouvoir désinfecter
des petits objets on a créé lui des boks
qui est un boîtier de 18 litres qui
permet de pouvoir d infecté en 30
secondes
les objets qui sont placés dans la
technologie utilisée à la diffusion de
rayons uv c à manier avec précaution car
potentiellement dangereux pour l'homme à
forte exposition les uvc sont efficaces
contre tout ce qui va contenir de l'adn
les virus les bactéries les sports les
champignons on a
dizaine d'années de d'études médicales
qui ont été menées sur différents germes
pour déterminer les doses nécessaires
pour désactiver tu es différent
pathogènes pour l'instant une dizaine de
lampes uv storm ainsi que 5 v boks ont
été assemblés au sein même de
l'entreprise
elle souhaite prioriser la production
sur le territoire c'est important de
pouvoir travailler le plus possible
localement d'avoir le plus possible de
la production et de la recherche et de
l'ingénierie qui est fait ici
l'entreprise travaille actuellement sur
un troisième produit adapté aux
particuliers notamment les ménages avec
enfants mais ces machines ne sont pas
des solutions miracles et doivent être
utilisés en complément des principaux
gestes barrières voilà je vous disais
les titres avec le confinement nous nous
sommes mises au désormais célèbre click
and collect mises en place par de
nombreux commerçants dits non essentiels
pour maintenir un peu d'activité pendant
ce confinement justement mais d'autres
pousse le concept à vendre à distance
encore plus loin c'est le cas du magasin
au coeur des artistes au mans dans la
sarthe qui a organisé cette semaine son
premier show live un télé achat en
direct sur instagram reportage d'anthony
python pour lm tv sartre sur place
regardez vous d'avoir dire bonsoir à
tout le monde
bienvenue sur cholet je ride aucun des
artistes
ce fauteuil est à la somme de 380 en
train de fermer ses portes dans le cadre
du confinement la boutique au coeur des
artistes innove en se mettant au
téléachat sur instagram
la première a eu lieu vendredi on peut
pas mettre en place un site internet
c'est trop compliqué avec notre notre
système de fonctionnement versée dès
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire parce qu'on
veut rester actif pour les créateurs
pour nous pour les clients qu'on
accueille en fait depuis cinq ans
maintenant et depuis une semaine on
réfléchit à l'articulation et voilà on a
fait de notre premier live the shop pour
cette première plus d'une quarantaine
d'articles de la boutique sont proposées
aux clients et les ventes sont conclues
en direct en fait le but c'était c'était
surtout de se marrer un petit peu de
temps même temps de monde tu dis encore
de de montrer la boutique de montres et
le magasin mais aussi de se marrer de se
détendre et donc on a fait 80 personnes
85 personnes tu très très bien moi je
suis super content
l'exercice a duré un peu plus d'une
heure dans une ambiance détendue
derrière son ordinateur amélie répond
aux questions des internautes et les
orientent pour les commandes c'était une
petite appréhension aussi nous on était
dans notre délire mais on savait pas si
le délire allait être partagé et là de
voir que les gens étaient là qu'il
restait qu'il fuyait pas au bout de deux
mondes c'était agréable et puis ça nous
rassure aussi de se dire que même si on
est ferment actuellement les gens sont
présents le prochain choc live du coeur
des artistes est prévue vendredi
prochain à 18h le rendez-vous est appelé
à se répéter une fois par semaine voilà
nous partons pour la loire maintenant et
plus précisément à saint-etienne où un
ancien centre commercial va devenir le
plus grand centre pluridisciplinaire de
santé de la métropole
il est situé en plein centre ville près
de 50 médecins et dentistes et autres
spécialistes devraient intégrer ce lieu
dans quelques mois les détails avec nos
confrères de tl7 télé loire 7 sur place
à l'abandon depuis des mois la galerie
dorion a enfin trouvé une nouvelle
vocation
d'ici 2021 les anciennes boutiques
accueilleront des cabinets de médecins
et les stéphanois semblent prêts à
troquer le shopping contre le centre
médical et je pense c'est bon et des
oeufs
parce que des pics est fermé c'est mort
déclare télé ces cas là je pense que
c'est plutôt un plus pour saint-etienne
parce qu'actuellement c'est plutôt un
désert médical
on a des rendez-vous six mois voire un
an après en avoir besoin
cinquante médecins de plusieurs
spécialités 25 dentiste mais aussi un
plateau de radiologie et de biologie
médicale seront installées dans la
galerie une offre de soins qui viendra
étoffer celle présente sur la ville et
augmenter le nombre de spécialistes
d'un point de vue de santé qui devrait
évidemment apporter une réponse à
beaucoup de nos concitoyens en matière
de délais notamment le rendez vous et
puis sur le centre-ville en annonce
entre 70 et 80 milles rendez vous par an
donc ça veut dire forcément une
attractivité nouvelle pour tout ce
secteur du centre-ville la cause m
et porteuses de projets elle possède
déjà dix centres de ce type sur paris et
en a développé son concept en province
joint par téléphone son directeur nous a
confié sa volonté de faire de ce centre
de santé
un vrai lieu de vie pour le président de
l'ordre des médecins le projet est
intéressant mais peut-être pas si facile
à réaliser
si réellement nous arriverons à trouver
50 médecins toutes spécialités
confondues venus plus des dentistes et
des kinés des sages-femmes et des
infirmiers nous serons sûrement les
premiers heureux à le voir mais ça fait
15 ans qu'on les cherche et on aimerait
bien savoir d'où ils viennent
en 25 ans le nombre de généralistes sur
saint-etienne serait passé de 207 à
moins de 180 l'ordre des médecins attend
avec impatience l'arrivée de nouvelles
forces vives
le début des travaux devraient débuter
d'ici la fin de l'année
voilà l'invitée du grand vite et des
territoires c'est anne charlotte
duvivier bonjour anne charlotte un
bonjour ça il est gay vous joins à tous
vous êtes directrice déléguée de wéo
picardie qui lance cette semaine une
opération sos commerce haute france
quelle est-elle pourquoi avoir lancé
cette opération
eh bah oui justement face à se confirmer
on a décidé de maintenance et une grande
opération solidaire pour bo picardie pee
wee au nord pas de calais bien
évidemment puisqu'on est sur deux
chaînes de télé un dans cette région des
hauts de france
on a lancé cette opération qui s'appelle
sos commerce des hauts de france on
invite tous les artisans et les
commerçants à nous contacter via une
adresse mail saint pey soes commerce à
tous et au point fr ils nous contactent
et ils viennent sur notre plateau nous
expliquer comment
il s'adapte au confinement comment ils
font évoluer leur manière de travailler
comment il se réinvente depuis qu'on a
lancé ça ça fait à peu près un peu plus
d'une semaine
on a énormément de demandes on est aussi
en train de créer une carte interactive
sur notre site internet pour tous n'est
répertorié pour finalement ma qu'on
puisse tout s'entraider et donc donc
voilà une belle opération solidaire qui
qui tourne actuellement sur nos deux
chaînes de télévision anne charlotte
duvivier le rôle de wéo picardie vous le
voyez comme le rôle d'une télévision
locale de service une télévision qui
aide les gens notamment dans cette
période de crise sanitaire
bah alors c'est tout notre c'est notre
adn cirque on informe les gens déjà sur
ce qui se passe et ce qu'ils ont droit
d'aller faire leurs courses avec des
amis ce qu'ils peuvent aller encore un
rendez vous médical on les informe au
plus près et on répond à leurs questions
parce que voilà où est où est plus que
jamais aux côtés des téléspectateurs et
des habitants de la picardie et de la
région des hauts de france
on adapte aussi nos programmes
évidemment et voilà plus que jamais on
laisse la parole aussi aux
téléspectateurs et aux habitants de 7,2
cette picarde y ait de cette région
parce que voilà il le faut il le faut
hajjar duvivier je le disais vous êtes
directrice déléguée de wéo picardie et
vous êtes dans les locaux du courrier
picard
donc le grand quotidien régional bien
sûr issus du même groupe que vous le
groupe recèle c'est important cette
coopération entre le courrier picard et
ueo picardie tout à fait évidemment
depuis 1 depuis longtemps la vidéo étant
partout c'est évident que la presse
quotidienne régionale ainsi que la télé
ont beaucoup davantage à travailler
ensemble ça va même plus loin en nord
pas de calais parce que du coup et même
diffusé sur le site de lavoixdunord.fr
ça viendra pour le courrier picard
dans un premier temps c'est sûr qu'il ya
des ya des échanges de vidéo mais il ya
aussi bas des journalistes du courrier
picard qui interviennent très
régulièrement sur notre antenne en
période d'élection les débats sont
évidemment co organisé avec la presse
quotidienne régionale
les gens de terrain qui s'allier avec
les gens de la télé pour faire des
débats animés
voilà ça a du sens tout ça voilà merci
anne charlotte duvivier d'avoir été
l'invitée du grand jt des territoires je
rappelle que vous êtes la directrice
déléguée de wéo picardie partenaire du
grand jt des territoires merci beaucoup
et vous à bientôt
les français pourront-ils s'offrir un
sapin naturel pour noël la question peut
légitimement se poser puisque vous savez
les producteurs ne peuvent pas en vendre
pour le moment pour un secteur qui fait
traditionnellement son chiffre
d'affaires pendant cette période bien
précise et bien le temps presse
sébastien germain de la chaîne 8 mont
blanc est allé à la rencontre d'un
producteur très inquiet à vallière en
haute-savoie voici son reportage regard
des produits saisonniers par excellence
le sapin de noël est il un produit
essentiel pour le moment pour le
gouvernement la réponse est non et chez
les producteurs à moins de trois
semaines du début habitués à des
expéditions
l'inquiétude règne c'est notamment le
cas de jean baptiste monde ou
propriétaire de 30 hectares et
producteur à va dire depuis maintenant
plus de 20 ans le discours de jean
castex de la semaine dernière dans les
produits essentiels et non essentiels
nous à nous à terrifier donc on est
vraiment très inquiet même si là à
l'heure où je parle je pense que on va
pouvoir faire cette saison de ça pas si
jamais arrivé qu'à quinze jours du début
des expéditions soit dans cet état
d'incertitudes pour bien comprendre ce
qu'impliquerait une interdiction de
vente des sapins
les chiffres sont assez explicites
chaque année jean baptiste monde où
vivent plus de 50 des sapins en trois
semaines soit l'intégralité de son
chiffre d'affaires il attend désormais
une clarification au sujet de la vente
de ces sapins nous embauchons est
effectivement plus de 100 personnes au
monde au moment des sapins de noël c'est
un symbole universel qui dépasse même la
religion chrétienne donc c'est un
symbole universel c'est l'arbre de vie
donc il faut le faire rentrer dans les
maisons et en plus un sapin de noël
naturels cultivés pour cela mais fort
heureusement les producteurs de sapins
ne sont pas seuls cyril elle va sénateur
de haute-savoie a récemment écrit au
premier ministre et au ministre de
l'agriculture pour leur demander une
autorisation de la vente de sapins à
partir du 25 novembre prochain en notre
rôle à nous parlementaires c'est de
pouvoir faire évoluer les choses et de
pouvoir faire prendre en considération
au niveau du gouvernement
des impacts sur le terrain de fait
pouvoir avancer un petit peu les choses
c'est pour éviter qu'on ait une
concentration de gens au même moment il
y avait en gros urgence à avoir une
décision
un arbitrage au niveau du gouvernement
pour que les producteurs puissent se
préparer et qu'on puisse le cas échéant
des 25 novembre avoir finalement une
filière d'approvisionnement qui soit
prête en attendant de savoir s'il pourra
vendre ces arbres de noël cette année
jean baptiste mandou ne se laisse pas
abattre la semaine dernière il a planté
huit mille jeunes norman qui arriveront
à maturité pour noël 2029
les fêtes de fin d'année toujours avec
les fameuses coquilles saint-jacques que
l'on adore déguster alors malgré le
confinement tente tant bien que mal de
pouvoir en trouver
reportage à boulogne-sur-mer de caroline
fichten pour la chaîne hbo la chaîne de
la voix du nord regardez c'est un bon
jour aujourd'hui pour les vendeurs de
poissons sur le port de boulogne il y a
un peu de monde et une aubette attire
particulièrement chez ginette propose
des coquilles saint jacques c'est la
saison et les amateurs sont nombreux
tiens toujours sur le port parce que moi
je sais que c'est frais et au moins
c'est de ce qu'on a la qualité quoi
voilà je vais pas au magasin tous
acheter le poisson les saint jacques
tout ça c'est toujours au port on est
des habitués gens qu'on shell et à pékin
que ça ne bouge pas en ce moment les
coquilles sont à 6 euros 50 le kilo 18
euros les 3 kg et sylvie peut même vous
les nettoyer ça va s'en mêle
alain bêta il ya deux sortes de
coquilles à des grosses il ya des plus
petites mais la noix les belles mais
comment ça vanne de courage sénégal
dans les cuisines du châtillon
restaurant emblématique situé dans la
zone portuaire de boulogne on continue
en cuisine à travailler les produits de
saison pour de la vente à emporter
au menu aujourd'hui des noix de saint
jacques rôties avec un risotto crémeux
aux herbes et un beurre blanc c'est un
produit qu'on aime bien parce qu'on
travaille bain juste une période assez
courte sur l'année et puis saint jacques
c'est simplement du beurre fondu
juste rôti de chaque côté deux minutes
maxi de chaque côté et c'est tout les
coquilles saint jacques sont souvent
synonymes de fête vous pouvez tout à
fait en acheter en ce moment et les
congeler mais vous pouvez aussi vous
faire plaisir tout de suite et vous
régaler je vous le disais dans les
titres nous partons maintenant pour les
montagnes des vosges à la découverte
d'une micro station de ski de moyenne
montagne d'ailleurs les équipes de via
vosges nos confrères sur place sont
allés découvrir la station de haut du
taux qui malgré le réchauffement
climatique et la crise va ouvrir ses
portes dans quelques semaines à
reportage de nos confrères deviendront
donc sur place encore quelques semaines
de patience une validation officielle du
préfet des vosges et c'est parti on
pourra de nouveau skier au haut du taux
ce qui n'était plus le cas depuis plus
de deux décennies
alors il ne s'agira pas de rouvrir un
grand domaine de ski alpin mais de
proposer trois pistes vertes d'une
centaine de mètres
parfait pour les débutants et c'est
l'aboutissement d'un projet de longue
haleine pour ceux qui en sont à
l'origine les membres de l'association
du téléski du haut du dos le projet
initial c'était la réouverture de
l'ancienne piste de ski du haut du taux
avec un téléski qui était qui
desservaient de piste rouge vraiment
très pentu donc ce projet il faut bien
se rendre à l'évidence même s'il n'est
pas arrêté il est en stand by
l'été dernier on a eu le bonheur de
pouvoir racheter hohwald à un fil neige
pour les débutants qui est quelque chose
de vraiment super c'est donc ce fil
neige racheter on l'a entendu cet été à
la station désormais fermé des hautes
navières hohwald 1 qui a permis de
concrétiser le projet un film neige qui
va d'ailleurs devenir unique en son
genre l'électricité nécessaire au moteur
sera produite par des panneaux
photovoltaïques
donc ce qui en fait vraiment quelque
chose d'unique et l'innovation bien sûr
un coût un peu plus de 30000 euros pour
le filmer
j'essaie neuf panneaux photovoltaïques
qui chargeront les batteries dès qu'il y
aura un minimum de lumière un
investissement donc mais l'association
est soutenue par les communes alentour
sapois gerba mon rocher sont vanier et
le syndicat et a reçu presque 22 mille
euros de fonds européens reste donc plus
qu'un seul problème celui de la neige
qui se fait de plus en plus rares mais
avec un équipement comme celui ci à 900
mètres d'altitude seuls quelques
centimètres suffisent
les pistes pourront même être pratiquée
l'été avec des skis à roulettes
l'ouverture est attendue pour fin
novembre début décembre en fonction de
la météo il vous en coûtera 5 euros la
journée et 3 euros pour les voilà
parlons à présent des initiatives
économiques dans nos territoires vous en
avez l'habitude dans son jt avec la
rubrique écorégions et jeux de société
produit en france ont la cote
le confinement à donner aux français de
nouvelles envies de ce côté là à
montpellier l'entreprise bioviva a bien
perçu ce phénomène
michel picaud bonjour bonjour je voulais
vous présenter aujourd'hui bioviva c'est
l'histoire d'un concepteur et fabricant
de jeux de société made in france et en
plus ils sont éco conçu la conception
c'est à montpellier que ça se passe
ensuite la fabrication est assurée par
l'entreprise graff hauts de saint paul
trois châteaux dans la drôme
tous les produits utilisent des encres
végétales des boîtes sans colle et en
bois provenant de forêts durablement
gérées et bien figurez vous qu'au delà
de la qualité des jeux l'entreprise
bioviva su convaincre les français sur
l'intérêt dû produire en france et en
plus avec des matériaux éco conçu la
crise sanitaire est passée par là le
marché du jouet a souffert puis s'est
retourné puis en recul lié à la
fermeture des magasins de jouets
notamment depuis plusieurs semaines mais
une prise de conscience semble faire son
chemin et le consommateur français veut
des produits français respectueux de
l'environnement c'est ce que fait
bioviva depuis 25 ans ils ont 25 ans
l'année prochaine
un anniversaire qui se célèbre ray par
une création d'une adaptation télé d'un
des jeux de bioviva voilà merci michel
picaud nous vous retrouvons dans une
prochaine édition
voilà si vous aimez les beaux stylos
comme moi et bien le grand jt des
territoires vous propose un reportage
qui va vous plaire on va sur les pas de
jules simoutre en moselle il a 24 ans
seulement il est déjà la tête d'une
véritable petite entreprise cet amoureux
du travail du bois ouvert il ya deux ans
sa fabrique de stylos artisanale depuis
il a ouvert une boutique à
moulins-lès-metz a été est labellisé une
formidable aventure qu'ils essaient de
maintenir à flot malgré l'épidémie à
reportage dorian vallot pour moselle tv
regarder depuis deux ans ces machines
outils fonctionnent à plein régime
et c'est dans sa toute nouvelle boutique
ouverte il ya un mois dans une rue très
fréquentée de moulins-lès-metz que je le
simoutre confectionne ses stylos
artisanaux chaque pièce est une création
unique fabriqué à partir d'une
soixantaine d'essences de bois
différentes du cerisier du charme ou
encore du waka pour venus tout droit du
brésil
ce militant anti déforestation donne une
seconde vie aux arbres fruitiers
français en fin de vie et
s'approvisionne en bois exotique à
travers une filière dont le bois est
issu du développement durable chaque
morceau de bois est différent et selon à
sa fragilité il peut être plus ou moins
abîmée plus ou moins poreux et c'est
donc il ya aussi ce risque-là c'est ce
qui me plaît parce que du coup ça rend
travail assez différent et c'est jamais
monotone parce qu'il faut s'adapter à
chaque morceau world le jeune artisan
entrepreneur propose trois types de
stylo plume euros leurs billes qu'il
peut personnaliser à la demande du
client
parmi les créations qu'il affectionne le
stylo en bois de mirabelliers de lui a
donné quelques sueurs froides au moment
de sa conception
au début ça a été très compliqué parce
que c'est c'est une essence de bois qui
est difficile à se procurer on peut pas
acheter de mirabelliers donc c'est
forcément vu par des connaissances par
des gens qui ont des vergers et donc une
fois que l'arbre ne donne plus de fruits
de pouvoir le travail et c'est quelque
chose d'important pour pour nous les
mosellans d'avoir
boone mirabelliers au bout des doigts
une passion que la pandémie mais comme
de nombreux commerces à rude épreuve les
fêtes de fin d'année correspondent à 40%
de son chiffre d'affaires alors je le
compte sur la vente en ligne pour sortir
son épingle du jeu malgré le confinement
le site commence à apprendre un peu plus
d'ampleur surtout aux abords des fêtes
de fin d'année forcément c'est pas trop
à quelle sauce on va être mangé pour la
fin d'année que tout peut encore varier
avec avec cette pandémie
maintenant je veux relativise en me
disant que je fais quelque chose que
j'aime que on aura quand même besoin de
faire des cadeaux pour noël parce que la
magie de noël personne n'enlèvera à 24
ans le jeune homme garde la tête sur les
épaules il veut malgré tout rester
optimiste et pendant cette période
morose
d'autant qu'il le sait il est encore
l'un des rares à pouvoir ouvrir ses
portes comme tous les spécialistes du
secteur de la papeterie
voilà et puis je signale l'édition
spéciale du magazine le point
cette fin de semaine consacrée à lille
c'est pas moins de 40 pages qui sont
consacrés à la métropole des hauts de
france avec évidemment l'art de vivre
les dégustations le match des gaufres
fourrées les bières des cavs a emporté
la gastronomie avec 5 reste au click and
collect comme on dit maintenant
et puis des sujets plus sérieux bien sûr
avec des bons plans ces petites
entreprises qui facilite la vie des gens
en période de confinement et puis xavier
bertrand son labo au banc d'essai de nos
confrères du point spécial l'île des
pages coordonné par audrey emery et
jérôme cordelier le rédacteur en chef
politique du point
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette édition
du grand jt des territoires sur vos
chaînes de télévision locales et
régionales et sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]